j'ai été c'est vrai ça fait maintenant
deux mois que j'étais venu pour parler
de ce drame et c'est vrai qu'à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui bon maintenant ça va un
peu mieux mais c'est vrai que du coup
bah c'est pour ça que moi j'ai mis du
temps en fait à peut-être reprendre la
parole ou même à faire un pas pour
envoyer justement cette lettre comme
comme vous l'avez dit alors c'est quoi
cette lettre en fait j'ai fait une
lettre parce que c'est vrai qu'à un
moment donné moi je me suis exprimé
c'est vrai dès le lendemain en fait ce
drame
et en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'après il y a eu tellement de
révélations différentes etc
en fait que il y a eu une confusion un
peu générale même me concernant c'est
vrai que j'ai reçu pas mal de choses
attaquantes
on a quelques extraits de la lettre que
tu que tu as transmises je vais me
permettre de de la lire à toi Pierre Le
cœur serré je t'écris cette lettre il
m'aura fallu deux mois pour arriver à
rédiger ces quelques mots qui te sont
destinés mon Dieu que la vie est dure
depuis cette nuit du 10 février 2023
cette tragédie cette tragédie a
bouleversé ta vie celle de tes proches
et aussi la mienne pourquoi la vôtre on
va revenir sur la lettre
oui
après c'est vrai que oui les victimes je
pense au quotidien c'est vrai enfin
quand on m'en parle ça fait on parle
beaucoup de cette affaire c'est vrai que
avant tout c'est les victimes il y a eu
des familles brisées donc oui tout à
fait pourquoi et pourquoi elle a changé
parce que c'est vrai que moi j'ai reçu
voilà fallait peut-être s'y prendre
aussi et ça je ne veux absolument pas me
dédouaner de cela mais c'est vrai que
c'était assez dur il y a eu beaucoup il
y a eu un déferlement voilà donc ça a
été compliqué moi à côté c'est vrai que
en plus
moi dans la vie c'est vrai que moi je
milite au quotidien contre les
discriminations contre le harcèlement
scolaire j'en ai fait un combat et c'est
vrai que du coup je me suis retrouvé un
peu dans cette situation où je dû faire
face à justement tout ce que je
combattais par rapport à mes différentes
actions donc c'est vrai que du jour au
lendemain aussi moi j'ai dû me justifier
sur pas mal de choses vous allez me dire
ce qui s'est passé parce que vous dites
à la plongée une famille dans le deuil
comme dit des Géraldine et mes pensées
ne peuvent se détacher d'elle de cette
affaire je ne suis que le dommage
collatéral d'une histoire passée si je
me suis exprimé à notre sujet ce n'était
ni pour te critiquer ni pour te défendre
mais simplement livrer mes vérités en
évitant ainsi que l'on invente les
miennes oui Jérémy oui qu'est-ce qu'on
vous a reproché exactement prendre la
lumière de d'occuper une place qui
n'était pas la vôtre harcèlement
exactement alors ça a été prendre la
lumière il y a eu certains en effet qui
ont critiqué là-dessus justement par
rapport à ça j'ai envie de dire
c'est vrai qu'ils sont pas moi de dans
ma vie donc il faut pas le voir
forcément mais c'est vrai que si j'avais
voulu vraiment cette lumière j'aurais
accepté tous les plateaux parce qu'il y
a plein de gens qui disent ouais vous
cherchez la Fame tout ça c'est du tout
vous le voyez ça je vous dis tout ce qui
se dit voilà sur voilà c'est bien que
vous répondiez ce soir comme ça là
absolument pas d'ailleurs bon j'ai une
preuve voilà c'est à dire que même ici
sur le plateau on m'a réinvité trois
quatre fois et moi-même j'ai dit moi je
ne souhaite pas montrer ma tête voilà
donc absolument pas ça je dis c'est pas
du tout le cas
et on m'a accusé ça on m'accusé après il
y a eu pas mal de choses aussi il y a eu
cette affaire justement un peu de pédo
pornographique est venu après etc donc
il y a une confusion en fait entre mon
témoignage qui est venu peut-être et là
je le dis peut-être tôt c'est à dire au
lendemain du drame et la semaine qui a
su mon témoignage j'ai eu beaucoup de
révélations donc un amalgame un petit
peu et c'est pour ça que j'étais un peu
attaqué en tous sens maintenant ça va
mieux parce que il y a eu plein de
choses qui se sont décantées on a une
réponse tu as une réponse de Pierre
Palmade ou pas non du tout je pense que
son avocat je sais qu'elle l'a reçu la
lettre moi son avocate pourquoi je
transmis ça c'est parce que j'avais été
entendu par la justice voilà dans cette
enquête et je vais dit justement il y a
là pour le coup elle m'avait répondu
j'avais dit que j'avais été entendu par
la justice
à ce sujet parce que moi je suis
transparent j'ai pas souhaité faire les
choses par derrière j'ai été
transparente depuis le début et c'est
pour ça que je l'ai prévenu et donc j'ai
envoyé une lettre par la caméra de son
avocate oui Valérie pourquoi l'avoir
rendu public cette lettre pourquoi vous
ne l'avez pas envoyé
je comprends tout à fait la question il
faut savoir que c'était une lettre
là il y a peut-être eu peut-être un
dixième voire un quinzième de la lettre
et en fait c'était aussi une façon pour
moi de tourner la page d'ailleurs ici
Cyril je peux le dire sur votre plateau
on m'a proposé plein d'autres émissions
etc que j'ai refusé et là si aujourd'hui
je suis là ceci pour pouvoir mettre un
terme justement moi maintenant je fais
ma vie à côté c'est aussi une façon de
tourner la page vous voyez que aussi le
les personnes qui m'ont connu par cette
affaire comprennent et sache que
justement ce sera mon dernier mot moi à
côté de ça justement j'ai pas mal de
conviction de choses comme ça ça m'a
beaucoup handicapé aussi par rapport à
mes combats par rapport à ma lutte et
c'est vrai que du coup je voulais mettre
un terme et c'est une façon si pour moi
de faire un peu le deuil là dessus
vraiment tu dois faire des signes je
suis pas fan non je suis pas fan comme
Valérie j'aurais préféré qu'il lui
envoie une lettre pour lui dire voilà on
met un terme à toute pas d'ambiguïté
j'ai été ton ex tous les ex de Pierre
Palmade n'ont pas fait une lettre comme
ça dans la presse je trouve que c'est
une manière de sauver ça sent le pétrin
il y a des histoires machin je me casse
et en plus je vais dans la lumière et
j'en profite pour faire un petit un
petit buzz et je viens à TPMP pour faire
un petit buzz sauf que c'était
nécessaire faire Palma il a pas besoin
de ça en ce moment il est dans une merde
qu'il a créé lui-même il va s'en sortir
lui-même il va être jugé comme il doit
être jugé mais votre démarche moi je la
kiffe pas trop je vous le dis en face je
kiffe pas trop je suis un peu comme
Valérie c'était pas la peine de la
rendre publique et j'ai l'impression que
on se sauve là tout le monde se sauve de
Pierre Palmade ah faut plus lui parler
on a fait la bringue avec lui pendant
des années on a fait les 400 coups avec
lui pendant des années mais là
maintenant qu'il est dans la mer moi je
ne veux pas que les gens me disent que
je suis son copain je trouve ça un peu
lâche moi j'aime pas les trucs comme ça
non mais on sent la sincérité c'est
c'est aussi pour vous presque une
analyse que vous faites de vous-même une
psychanalyse d'écrire ça mais quand même
Jérémy quand on écrit une lettre on
attend une réponse vous aimeriez faire
Palma que vous répondre et s'il vous
répondez est-ce que vous seriez prêt à
aller le voir
pour l'instant c'est c'est
dur aussi de répondre à ça même moi-même
de me positionner comme je l'ai dit
c'est vrai que toute cette histoire
forcément ça ça bouleversé aussi
moi-même ma propre vie mon quotidien etc
donc alors d'aujourd'hui et c'est pas
pour justement
me sauver justement parce qu'il faut
savoir que lorsqu'il y a eu des
révélations voilà j'étais le premier à
justement apporter des éléments contre
d'ailleurs on a vu quelqu'un qui a été
jugé là il y a quelques jours puisqu'il
avait voulu profiter justement lui moi
il faut savoir que par rapport à ça
j'étais le premier à pouvoir témoigner
pour justement qu'il soit pas enterré
plus qu'il ne l'est voilà mais je
comprends tout à fait ce que Raymond
vous dites j'entends extrêmement bien ce
que les chroniqueurs ont à dire et
d'ailleurs si je suis là aussi voilà
d'une part c'est aussi pour pouvoir me
justifier m'expliquer je comprends que
ça ait pu provoquer des réactions
après moi même par rapport justement aux
réactions négatives qu'il y a eu au
déferlement vous êtes aussi peut-être
place bien placé pour le savoir c'est à
dire que dès qu'on prend position sur
tel ou tel sujet on va forcément avoir
des critiques on va forcément avoir du
mauvais moi c'est arrivé en fait du jour
au lendemain et réellement moi je me
serais passé avec le recul lorsque j'y
repense non mais en fait je me serais
remplacé concrètement Jérémy parce que
pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
rejoignent à 20h51 dans un instant on va
vous révéler les les photos qu'il y a
dans Paris Match et les dernières
révélations sur cette affaire puisque
Jérémy locoche avec nous et vous allez
voir c'est vrai Benjamin action Benjamin
monsieur Jérémy et Benjamin sera avec
nous il est juste là rédacteur en chef
culture par un match sera avec nous et
vous allez voir ce que contient
l'article c'est vraiment il y a des
révélations incroyables juste j'ai rien
en fait il s'est passé quoi après
l'émission vous avez reçu quoi vous avez
reçu des des menaces ça a été et genre
quoi c'était des menaces a été ça a pu
être dû bon voilà tu es un manque rien
etc voilà ça peut être de ça jusqu'à on
va les insultes homophobes oui alors il
y a eu alors justement les les insultes
homophobes là ça a fusée oui il y a eu
beaucoup d'insultes homophobes et puis
il y a eu un amalgame dans cette
histoire c'est à dire qu'en fait le cas
Pierre Palmade ça a fait resurgir
peut-être également parce que moi je
suis activiste comme je vous l'ai dit
militant contre l'homophobie contre le
harcèlement etc et moi j'ai beaucoup
d'associations qui m'ont dit mais oui
c'est vrai que c'était terrible ce drame
parce que ça a fait surgir le mauvais
côté également et les pans peut-être
difficile donc c'est vrai que
l'homophobie ça a fait partie ça a été
les pires insultes ça a été un
déferlement l'homophobie etc et c'est
pour ça que alors d'aujourd'hui moi pour
me sauver aussi et pour pouvoir aller
mieux et que ça ne finisse pas dans une
dépression etc je me suis dit voilà je
mets un terme aujourd'hui Cyril merci de
m'avoir donné ce sera ce sera la
dernière fois où je m'exprimerai une
voiture
ce sera à la fois où j'en parle moi ça
m'a énormément peiné pénalisé et moi
maintenant je me reconcentre uniquement
sur mes combats contre le harcèlement
illumination ce que je combat il faut
savoir avancer maintenant j'ai dit il
faut savoir avancer parce qu'il y a des
choses qui ont été faites dans le passé
mais maintenant le passé c'est le
il faut se construire sur l'avenir et
par ça c'est le passé parce que de toute
façon ce qui est fait est fait et il y
aura un procès pour ce qui s'est passé
et puis maintenant chacun doit tourner
sa page et puis voilà parce que
les menaces faut pas hésiter à
l'hypothèse ou vous auriez une réponse
une réponse de Pierre Palmade à la
lettre que vous avez envoyé à l'avocat
est-ce que vous allez aussi la rendre
public et la publier sur les réseaux
sociaux ça va rester de l'ordre de
l'intime du coup j'ai compris on apprend
de ces erreurs
j'ai compris que dans cette affaire je
me suis retrouvé du jour au lendemain un
peu comme dans un tourbillon j'ai pas su
forcément faire et j'ai été peut-être
maladroit donc à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
non non non non non non parce que quand
on l'écoute on dirait que c'est vous la
victime
c'est quand même vous qui vous êtes
exposé moi je sais pas moi quand on aime
quelqu'un on s'expose pas comme ça on
vous écoute là on dirait la veuve est
pleurer et c'est c'est assez terrible je
trouve moi ça me choque à votre
comportement je vous assure moi ça me
choque énormément ce que vous faites là
pourquoi pourquoi parce que c'est allé
comme ça les affaires est déjà
douloureuse il y a effectivement des
familles qui souffrent il y a eu un
drame épouvantable pierre viendra aussi
épouvantable et vous vous êtes là vous
parlez vous exposez les lettres